oui bonjour à vous tous bonjour jimmy
notre invité ce matin et aux bras d'or
bonjour bonjour alors vous êtes
directrice du parc naturel marin de
martinique vous êtes avant tout
océanographe et c'est bien parce que
vous l'êtes que vous avez été nommé
aussi à ce poste à la direction du parc
naturel marin retracer nous d'abord
succinctement votre parcours
professionnel au bras d'or vous êtes
martiniquaise vous êtes né en martinique
vous avez fait vos études ici voilà la
scolarité peu que j'ai effectivement
commencé ma scolarité en martinique ou
lycée schoelcher lisse et beaucoup de
personnes affectionne et puis je me suis
dirigé vers l'hexagone pour poursuivre
des études d'océanographie d'abord à
montpellier où je me suis attaché plutôt
géosciences marines donc vraiment à
l'aspect plutôt physique à l'aspect
courantologie géologie des fonds marins
j'ai poursuivi à marseille est une ville
qui est très accueillante qui accueille
tout le monde et qui effectivement très
intéressante en termes d'études
puisqu'on peut il ya effectué pas mal de
cursus et justement faire des ponts
entre les filières donc j'ai pu intégrer
le centre d'océanologie de marseille
pour être effectivement c'est un
autographe après d'autres études m'ont
permis de réfléchir à cet équilibre
entre écologie et économie donc j'ai
poursuivi après avec un billet qui est
plus quand on voit la master key est
plus une formation mains canadiennes
nous amène aux américaines qui permet de
travailler sur les modèles d'affaires
sur l'évolution à dire de de l'action
privée initialement et donc pour moi
c'était cette formation à la fois
scientifique et aussi de cette formation
m billet ces deux formations ont permis
de comprendre qu'il faut absolument
réussir à à rendre accessible
l'information écologique à la faire
partager pour que tout le monde à la
fois les acteurs privés à la fois le
grand public puisse être un acteur réel
de la protection de l'environnement en
quelques mots pourquoi avoir choisi de
revenir en martinique à ce poste alors
que bon manifestement vous auriez pu
faire une carrière voire même
internationale c'est vrai que le retour
au pays et y avoir une vraie question
est on
longtemps ici un enjeu quand on parle
pourquoi revenir alors que des horizons
s'ouvrent à nous je suis revenu d'abord
pour proférer un stage parce que je
revenais pas et le parc naturel régional
m'a permis également la mairie de sainte
anne m'ont permis de toucher à l'action
locale elle doit rendre compte qu'on
avait effectivement de la place
pour des compétences pour développer ses
compétences pour agir au niveau de la
martinique puisque océanographes on est
entouré d'eau donc forcément il y avait
de la place et il y avait tout un champ
investir pour faire en sorte que les
politiques maritimes soit soit des
politiques développées aussi par les
territoires et par la martinique c'est
tout le défi qui vous attend justement
en tant que directrice du parc naturel
marin de martinique alors vous avez
commencé effectivement puisque vous êtes
la première directrice ses seins depuis
son installation alors c'était en
l'installation était en 2017 mais je
crois que bon il a fallu un certain
temps vous êtes en poste depuis 2000
18000 valises à homs et ça exactement
qui est d'abord la création juridique il
fallait faire vraiment un décret
interministériel pour donner du du
fondement juridique au parc naturel
marin ça a été fait en 2017 et l'équipe
en place il fallait la créer et donc je
suis arrivé en mai 2018 et depuis après
2020 nous avons une vitesse de croisière
donc un effectif de 18 agents qui sont
un dédié à la gestion de ces terres
marines protégées y voilà donc quatre
d'activité et d'action pour le parc
naturel marin de martinique que vous
dirigez avec le président olivier marie
reine puisque cet organisme est
actuellement présidée par par olivier
marie reine donc vous avez tenure et
très récemment un conseil de gestion
c'était le 21 dernier un conseil de
gestion du parc naturel marin qui compte
53 membres alors occasion de faire le
bilan d'activité de l'année dernière
qu'en ressort-il de plus saillants
obrador alors ce qui est ressorti vous
êtes années 2020 tiens c'est qu'on a
réussi à valider un document qui était
fondateur c'est le plan de gestion donc
certes c'est un document donc pour le
grand public il n'y a pas tout de suite
de l'inrab était déjà validé depuis l'an
dernier le
processus de validation qui fait que
tout au long on va dire de l'année 2021
il fallait passer les étapes pour qu'il
soit prouvé reconnu aura des hauts
niveaux cyrielle et qu'il est vraiment
son poids donc le conseil de gestion la
travailler dès l'installation du parc a
mis en évidence des éléments phares ce
fameux équilibre qu'il faut trouver
entre équilibre et développement ce
curseur où on le positionne et surtout
comment on intègre les toutes les
parties prenantes notamment la
population à positionner bien ce curseur
ce travail était fait effectivement
depuis la mise en place du pin mais il a
été validé il a fallu le porter pour
qu'il soit effectivement totalement au
cloud d'autant que c'est important parce
que il il engage pour kazan il un gastro
chaîne allure exactement ça nous ça nous
met dans une perspective de 2035 ça nous
fait comprendre très clairement ce plan
de gestion qu'on travaille pas pour nous
mais bien pour les générations futures
on a d'ailleurs on sait d'ailleurs
attaché à demander aux scolaires
puisqu'on travaille pas ou en 2035 izon
25-30 en tout cas ce sont eux les
adultes qui vont profiter du travail du
poc marin donc on les a questionnés sur
leurs ambitions sur leur finalité sur
leur vision sur les exigences de presse
qu'ils peuvent formuler donc 2021 pour
moi ça a été on va dire la réussite a
été de faire que ce plan de gestion qui
aurait traduit l'ambition la volonté des
uns et des autres sera reconnue au plus
haut niveau mais alors on y revient
parce que vous avez expliqué vous dites
qu'il n'a pas été simple a alors il a
été validé mais ensuite ça a commencé à
mettre en oeuvre a constitué car il
s'agit aussi finalement pour les 15
prochaines années vous l'avez dit de
trouver un équilibre entre environnement
économie c'est-à-dire souci de la
protection de l'environnement et bien
sûr volonté du développement économique
ces deux de thématiques on a tendance à
opposer d'ailleurs j'ai dans le parcours
d'un parcours d'études c'était pour moi
intéressant de faire c'est un billet
pour réussir à comprendre comment on
peut parler le même langage donc à les
rendre compatibles à les rendre
compatibles sur les fusions c'est un
défi et pour autant je vais commencer
avant de répondre à cette question à
faire une analogie avec une espèce avec
les récifs coralliens les lessives
coralliens doivent nous nous éclairer
nous faire réfléchir parce que ce sont
des animaux et des végétaux donc deux
mondes le monde animal monde végétal qui
s'associent pour construire autre chose
du minéral et c'est finalement ce récif
corallien qui le plus constructeurs
c'est l'élément le plus bio
constructeurs de la planète c'est ce
courage parce qu il
larry va faire quoi associer des choses
qui sont opposés et pour moi l'idée
c'est ça c'est de bien montrer que
finalement pour construire on ne pourra
pas construire dans l'opposition on ne
pourra pas construire dans du tout dans
tout sanctuary zeew dans du tout
développement et qu'effectivement très
concrètement parce qu'après dans le
document c'est facile à écrire c'est
après dans les projets est aussi l'année
2020 tiens nous a permis de commencer à
toucher du doigt en rendant des avis
conformes à montrer comment trouves cet
équilibre donc le parc naturel marin le
conseil de gestion rendu quatre avis
conforme sur l'installation du câble d
edf sur la le système de traitement de
dillon un autre sur un projet de
mouillage à saint pierre et tout ça nous
montre bien qu'il faut beaucoup de
débats et qu'on a réussi avec
effectivement du débat à trouver a donné
un avis favorable mais aussi a donné un
avis défavorable parce que le curseur
doit être bien positionné papon nous pas
pour les intérêts de tous ceux qui sont
dans la salle mais pau les générations
futures dans 15 ans alors un champ
d'intervention aussi que vous avez au
parc naturel marin de martinique c'est
de se préoccuper et de faire en sorte
que la qualité des eaux mien soit
maximum 1 en tout cas dans la mesure du
possible alors on parle de kells aulas
et éventuels évidemment ces parcs
naturels marins donc c'est l'eau de mer
mais dont qualité des eaux pour la pêche
pour la baignade pour eux pourquoi pour
l'aquaculture la qualité des eaux c'est
le départ de tout sans une bonne qualité
des ondes peut ni faire de pêche niffer
d'aquaculture n'ai rien faire du tout
sur notre territoire la partie terrestre
on a 160 et une rivière et 43 ravine
donc notre réseau hydrographique montre
bien que oui tout la riviera et dans
l'eau mais c'est une réalité donc ça
commence effectivement presque depuis la
montagne pelée s'il faut bien quand ils
ont depuis le source de riz vieux puis
voilà jusqu'à laval jusqu'au bassin qui
reçoit jusque effectivement à la mer à
ces masses d'eau qui dans lesquels on
prend plaisir à se baigner donc la
qualité des eaux pourquoi pour la
baignade avant tout parce
qu'effectivement main le martiniquais
tient son de belle-mère et nous aussi on
tient là dans quelques autres actions
dans ce domaine très concrètement notre
action c'est le premier levier le levier
le plus fort sera l'avis conforme
effectivement
nous avons eu comme je disais à rendre
quatre avis conforme un des avis
conformes correspondait à la
régularisation de systèmes de traitement
notamment celui de dillon et nous avons
signalé très fortement notre ambition
est donné un avis défavorable donc ce
qui oblige le porteur de projet à revoir
sa copie à mettre au niveau d'exigence
plus forte quand le parc naturel marin
le conseil de gestion estime qu'il ya un
risque qui a un effet notable d'un
projet sur la qualité des masses d'eau
son pouvoir effectivement et à ce moment
là très fort parce qu'il peut dire non
projet seulement d'alerté vous pouvez
quelque part bloqué entre guillemets ou
en tout cas mettre en stand by et dire
revoyez votre copie et
alors ça c'est vraiment qu'on est arrivé
en bout de chaîne parce qu'en préalable
on a une action de prévention de
collaboration notamment avec l'office de
l'eau qui gère un document qui porte un
document qui est très important qui a
été d'ailleurs validé hier qu'est le
sdage le schéma directeur d'aménagement
et de gestion des eaux donc dans ce
document il ya des prérogatives des
préconisations et des seuils donc toute
cette dynamique là nous permet on espère
d'arriver avec des avis conformes qu'on
espère favorable parce qu'on aura fait
un travail en amont c'est à chacun aussi
parce que l'action des porteurs de
projets donc de certaines collectivités
ou de certains privés sont soumis aux
regards effectivement dû du parc quand
il ya un effet notable mais chacun dans
notre quotidien aussi on a une action
quand on construit un assainissement
c'est aussi un sujet fort très bien il
nous reste une minute aux deux bras d'or
directrice du parc naturel marin de
martinique pour cette première partie
d'émission le projet phare du programme
2022 alan est déjà bien entamée mais
enfin voilà à rose hill c'est difficile
de répondre à cette question parce qu'on
a beaucoup de projets alors je peux vous
mettre une sur une piste peut-être
narbonne non
je vais garder
ma réponse je vais quand même temps
donner 2 le preuve la première action
c'est la mise en place du service
opérations un parc naturel effectivement
existe parce qu'on donne des avis mais
il doit être sur le terrain à la
rencontre de la population pour la
sensibiliser donc là on a réussi à
recruter des jeunes qui sont en
formation des gens aussi expérimenté
donc ça c'est la première action valait
au contact avec notre bateau de la
population pourrait sensibiliser la
deuxième action bien a abondé plus
jeunes et notamment les plus jeunes la
deuxième action
même s'il ya des actions de connaissance
je vais vraiment mettre le zoom sur une
action une invitation on à vis de la
population en juin du 6 au 12 au bélier
a de la merde ont gardé contact avec
nous sur notre page facebook et vous
aurez losio là ni bien sûr moi nous nous
en ferons l'écho évidemment merci
beaucoup voilà pour cette première
partie de nuit